البشريه في خطر للاسف لعادل ولكن السبب هو
الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا حديث الساعه الان
نعم راويه الحقيقه هذا ما حذر منه العديد
من الخبراء التقنيين الذين يرون ان هذا
الذكاء المرعب بين
ضفيرتين قد يؤدي الى انقراض البشريه
العلماء الذكاء الاصطناعي اولويه عالميه
العلماء وصفوا هذا الخطر بانه يوازي اخطار
حروب اوبئه والخطر النووي فيما وصفه اخرون
ان هذه المخاوف مبالغ فيها
لافته في الموضوع بانه هذه المخاوف جاءت
من رواد ويعني اباء الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذكاء الاصطناعي بدنا نشوف الله يستر فيه
يعني بيقول خلال خمس سنوات ممكن تدمر
البشريه من
متابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات